they're coming to you from ETS Comicon
suite with the cast of the flash for all
the fans who are tuning in right now
they're probably not gonna be able to
make it to our panel this evening so
this is going to be kind of a mini panel
for them to enjoy at home so first off
West Island family you'll be looking
great I've got a note what was your
initial reaction when you found out that
Nora West Allen was going to be coming
back from the future and visiting her
parents I was excited I thought was a
cool storyline to do I mean especially
when we started teasing Jessica and
seeing like how she brought really cool
elements I think of like kind of Barry
and iris yeah it's kind of yeah reminds
me of like season one kind of tone a
little bit so it's been great and the
first time I saw Jessica I was literally
looking at her like this is so well
Jessica
Danny Hartley this is your first
comic-con here at the cast as series
regulars how are you feeling sick
nervous anxious yeah it's awesome
terrible I've been here before but I
think being here with all these guys is
a completely different experience
because it's like an actual comic and
the fans are very intense here so it's
kind of it's a little nerve-wracking but
it's it's mostly very exciting I from
there honored for it's not fun to be on
a show that people watched yeah I prefer
it I've been on more than one show that
you know me and my mom watch Oh baby
it's it's really exciting to come here
and be on a show that people really
really care about and they're invested
in and you're not really selling the
show to them they're excited to come and
share the
experience with you yeah well said girl
yeah bro for our og flash family going
into season 5 what does the vibe feel
like on set I know we were talking about
this a little bit like last night then
it's gonna be such an amazing season
yeah I mean season 5 to me for me it
feels like we never left like this year
it really feels like we never left it's
just yeah yeah my good spirits the
scripts are great you know it we're
excited yeah it's very good energy I
think having you guys honestly is such a
energy Reviver for us it's good it's
good having new and I've got one new
thing that I'm really excited about but
now I'll talk about it yeah but this
season just so exciting and fun for me
and you guys will know soon know we'll
probably be talking about it on the
panel well I gotta get a shot give a
shout out Danielle you are making your
directorial debut how's the preparation
going and how does it feel to knowing
that you're gonna be stepping behind the
camera this year it's great I'm so
excited
yeah I think we're so lucky to be on a
show that it's gonna hit a hundred
episodes this year and I've you know I
was totally inspired by Tom Cavanagh and
his work in season three in season four
so I'm excited to collaborate with these
guys make it fun episode I'm staring at
the cast and thinking about the
characters and I can't help but see that
we have two bachelors this year because
you know Cisco and Ralph your characters
romance as they look for some romance
romance as we look for romance I mean
you know I I think I think Cisco
struggling at the at the top of of
season five in the wake of the you know
Cindy breakup and so Ralph
I think seize that opportunity to take
him under his wing and
sort of introduced into some methods
some time tested Divini methods Jim you
know helping Cisco get over his breakup
what if you guys tried to date our
daughter with the introduction of your
grown-up daughter how is that going to
affect theory and IRS moving forward how
their relationship speed bumps is what's
great about this season it's just iris
and steadfast and rope no issues
relationship wise were just a we know of
it and we know yeah it feels like it's
gonna be like any family issues will be
more connected to us dealing with this
you know Candice you know I gotta ask
you every time what is the status on
reporter iris west-allen
I bring good news my friend he is coming
back this season finally I'm very happy
about it I know the fans are really
excited to see that so we are working
very hard to make that a reality on
their show and Danielle to give me
killer frost updates for us when we last
saw a flashback to young Caitlin it
seemed like killer frost was within her
the entire time please tell me we're
gonna get some answers I hope so I think
you know I think we've talked a little
bit about our theme this year is about
family so we're gonna get to explore a
little bit more of Caitlin's roots and
try and figure out where these powers
came from she may need the help of a
detective maybe
oh well speaking of family you know
there's a new family member in the West
family indeed um
still got the power how is the
introduction of a new baby girl going to
shake up their dynamic um I think in a
good way but I for me I enjoy bringing
to the show that kind of like element of
you know excitement and happy to be part
of it my character reflects my real-life
feelings which is super happy to be part
of this family and clearly the most
enthusiastic new member so I think I
think it's kind of the same thing
happening that Joe and Cecile sort of
get this fresh start and fresh eyes to
look at everything through well lastly
we are going to be talking about this a
lot more on the panel and fans can keep
it locked to ichi online.com forward
slash aimless flood um what can you
tease for the fans out there about the
big bad this year it's gonna be unlike
anything we've ever seen yeah really
scary
yeah it's a really interesting the
casting of them in italics right really
interesting that's cool can see that
he's not a speedster yeah yeah we just
said that he's a man we had a teaser for
him that was supposed to air at the end
of last season and we're showing at the
beginning of this season instead so yeah
it's really it's a cool little segment
thank you guys so much for speeding on
over here and to just let the fans know
we had a Tom Cavanaugh is just he's not
here but we love him and we'll be
getting it and also I have to say they
asked us to sit in the front row long
ago
I only get the magazine the shortest Oh
always
holy Thank You flash family I adore you
so much thank you to the fans keep it
locked to et all day for more interviews
with your favorite cast from comic-con
[Music]